good morning John I just have to start
this video by thanking the Yeti for
vetoing at least half of that beard
green men were just not meant to wear
beards the part on your face wasn't so
bad but the problem is that the neck see
this grow significantly faster than the
rest of the face I personally cannot
grow a beard at all only on the neck the
chin and the mustache so I could have a
neck chin mustache beard and that would
look really bad because neck beards
always look really bad it's like you
swallowed a weasel and then it got stuck
and then it died trying to claw its way
out of your neck I am not worried at all
frankly about my inability to grow a
beard what I want is for it not to grow
at all I mean I don't have to shave like
a normal man but I do have to shave like
once every week and that is annoying in
fact I think I'm due right now shaving
is painful and bothersome and I don't
want to have to do it if I am incapable
of growing a beard the world is so
unfair in fact John you and I just had a
conversation on instant messenger
something which we can do now for those
of you who have not caught up on the
rules about fairness and about how the
world just isn't fair and if it were our
lives would suck a lot more because if
you're watching this video chances are
your life is like 10 times better than
the other person in the world things
like clean water a roof over your head
hot showers all these things that not
everybody has every time I think to
myself god that just isn't fair I'm like
wow really really Hank it isn't fair
because it was fair you have eaten poop
at least once in your life and I don't
want to eat poop anyway what was I
talking about I was talking about beards
I was talking about shaving and I don't
like shaving because that time could be
better spent doing awesome things like
watching YouTube videos or playing Wii
Fit that's right
I got a Wii Fit it's really heavy
probably not a good sign now we're
playing which is heavier the week bid is
heavier than the cat the cat is cuter
than the wee bit though so now I get to
find out my body mass index and whether
or not my mean will be portly too fun
for old people I think I've already
figured out the most effective strategy
for using the Wii Fit and a fitness
program yeah yeah do one of these that's
good
you know my lumbar is burning yeah yeah
I couldn't be very much less manly right
now I have a hard time imagining this is
going to be better for my health than my
High School Musical 3 DVR dance pad
which by the way was only twenty dollars
I'm not confident that I'm gonna get my
money's worth out of this but so goes
the Brotherhood 2.0 what is it called
did you call it what did you call it I
don't remember what it's called
yeah so John I'm ready to take you on I
just did a bunch of push-ups okay like
six and it's six push-ups but I grow
muscles fast and my Wii Fit age has
already changed from 28 the first day to
45 the second day I don't think the Wii
Fit age thing is entirely accurate but
my body mass index went down I am
totally gonna pone you in body mass
index I started out at 24 and I only got
to get to 22 so you are dead in that
category
you better start pushing up my friend
you had better start pushing up anyway I
have to make the collab video that John
and I are doing for Monday it's very
exciting and totally top-secret so stay
tuned for that John I will be seeing you
constantly as I edit this video